good mid-morning Millennials welcome
back to the morning toast hey guys it's
Claudia how's everyone doing um I'm
feeling really tired and exhausted and I
really wish I pulled trigger and just
throw up last night because I'm not
feeling good like it's it's it's bad
it's bad and counselors made John Fitch
cam how are you doing okay like I just I
just know it's gonna get worse
throughout the day that's where I am
right that's where the pain and sadness
like gets to me as well who do you think
is worse off right now well I did go to
bed later because I dropped Margo off
because I'm a nice sister minute every
it made it such a big difference you
have no idea like I was in this car like
with my eyes rolling behind my head like
alone okay for 30 bucks I want to hear
about the rest of the night because as
you all know we had you know there was a
stark difference between our statuses
today because I went home at Grandma's
curfew around 12:30 and you know what
usually I like really admire like your
ability to just like get out of town and
like you will usually make the right
choice in like leaving look like it's
always the right call then I'm like at
this terrible party being like wow
Jackie's asleep and like not to rub it
in your face but like we had the night
of our yeah it wasn't in the cards for
me regardless because I was having
cramps like my stomach was really
hurting at the bar that we were at so
that wasn't gonna change even if we went
to a better club for me but I'm still
good because I really wanted you to have
a good night because you were really
gonna know I like we are not here for a
long time we're here for a [ __ ] good
time like we were it was I left my house
with the intention of feeling like this
I don't even mad like honestly I totally
this is what I wanted these are battle
scars I'm proud as [ __ ] we stayed out
till sunrise I was getting into bed my I
saw light outside till the break of dawn
to break it up dog-eat-dog [ __ ] tonight
again run - yeah let's go we had such a
great crew okay who stayed surprised I
saw some on your story but I was like in
between snoozes and they actually
weren't storying at all I know because
you
Acme was underground and I had no
service see you attack me okay so we
went to dinner which was such a jolly
good time I can't believe that since I'm
in high school the only good restaurant
in this city is the same yeah a great
catch good food and like normal people I
can't believe that people get dressed up
it's the place to be and we had the
intention of going to flaming saddles
which is a country gay bar that like
we've never been to but it's like so
poppin and we'd heard so many good
things about and that was like our
nights plan and we pull up after dinner
with like full bellies smile survived
and it's just like was not it like what
we were looking for and it was really
disappointing and I like to felt bad cuz
like I made the group go like so far out
of the way and then like all of us are
in this bar where it's a house kitchen
where I just like wasn't it I mean I
ended up going to like a bar on the next
block which is like a popular Hell's
Kitchen gay bar and it was so [ __ ]
late we walked in they were playing
literally the song had just started as I
set in it's like they pressed a play for
me well I know when I hear that song
it's meant to like you're gonna have a
rager night like your life's never gonna
be the same and we stay there for a
little while they started playing porn
and that's when I was like feeling
uncomfortable with Margo and I was like
we gotta go yeah I stay for the porn and
then I left I love her sign I saw a
penis
again I did I kept adds to like the UM
Yeol's
you know it did and it took me a long
time to realize that it was I thought
was a musical part of the weekends music
video but then I realized the song was I
feel it coming yeah and they were they
made them on time slicing it it was a
montage it's porn so that's where the
group split up because it was really the
night you know there comes a point in
everyone's life when it's either time to
go home or it's time to brave brave the
note to hunker down and double that and
we didn't have plans that was the thing
that was so annoying about you know cuz
I guess like I have no friends and I was
like looking at my phone like what's
everyone doing it or like who's everyone
I don't know and that's the tough thing
about the about having no friends it's
like we we were like should we just go
and like see but it's like such a long
drive like it's just really taking a
chance on some unknown clubs and you
know I used to run this town back in
back in my day but I haven't been in the
club scene in a while
New York's Club scenes now what you
to be and I just don't know like what
the hotspots anymore like there was a
time when I was out at Paul's
Casablancas till 6 a.m. like multiple
times a week and like you I've been
there when they turn the lights on like
that's what like you know you have a
problem they like literally like ask you
to leave and I was like now party's
still going like that was me but like I
don't know I just feel like I'm past
that and I don't really know what like
the club scene is like do you Margo do
you club no I am scenic I like bars yeah
well so so it ended up being me and
snitch Margo lemon right which is what I
expected and then Dana and I thought she
was like totally gonna go home like
she's going to Greece today she's doing
agrees she has a live-in boyfriend like
you know what she does that work oh so
me Olivia Kristen had left that would
have given anyone an excuse like half
half the girl one would have played
anyone forgot me home sis that's a great
craft so we got an uber exhaling we went
to Acme which you know I'm in attacked
me in a while in the last time I was
there I yelled at someone and like she
really needed that but like I just every
time I go there I think about the good
person that I knew yeah and like Margo
necessary I'll tell you no sorry we had
seitan here Barry look honestly maybe
the best night of my life
second best I mean when she act me and
it's like oh okay this is where the cool
people have been hiding for years it was
just it wasn't too packed it was like a
bar but also a club they're playing
great music they played Stacy's mom just
really I would say a premium nightlife
experience yeah agreed and they was like
sad you know it's really sad a table how
does it work nobody just we were just
chillin just posted we just posted it
was you know it's like it's sad about
going out it's like when you're finally
having a good time like people start to
leave and I was like looking around like
it was emptying and I'm like it's like
2:00 in the morning I'm like no I'm
finally having fun like yeah we're gonna
say we're gonna have a good [ __ ] time
okay it's really annoying
so we didn't what the night end and
we're like ok where should we go next
cuz like we couldn't believe that just
like things were happening you know I'm
sure I was really shocked when I saw a
challenge event at 4:24 a.m. right so
then we were like ok what's next
and we're like what's the next club and
we're like what's the after party now
and it's always one oak and it's like
never fun and we're like tonight's the
night of taking the chance on some
unknown venues let's go so we went to
one oak and it was [ __ ] late like oh
my god Oh Margo had like a pimp I don't
know I was no where we no no it's just
so funny like I'm always in charge of
making plans like I haven't paid about
like getting like I'm always the
director but it was nice just to be like
an idiot girl for the night who just
like was floating around I'm getting in
places you know I you know if I was
there none of that ever works out for me
and I'm always like standing on a line
for Club and going home so like be
grateful I didn't come because none of
this would have happened
ok I appreciate a [ __ ] crossing there
and the snitch no I know exactly what
you're saying and that's my lesson I
just like couldn't believe everything
was working out in my day they left ok
thank you
um and like I just I couldn't let the
night end because there there will never
be another night where like things are
working properly
so we go to 1 oak we're like there and
it's so crazy because we're like looking
each other it was so late but one oak is
like a times a time warp or it's like
time doesn't exist because there
probably was just as busy at 4:00 a.m.
as they were at 1:00
it's so crazy I could I don't even know
what to how late was because everyone
there is just like it's regular so we
were bumping and bopping and you know
dance to the music taking a couple drags
we were drinking a little too much and I
took a like half a shot at one open
that's when I knew I needed to go home I
stopped drinking at acne because he was
like I was good [ __ ] up I was like I
just don't want to ruin this they [ __ ]
up this yeah I don't have that quality
like to be able to stop stop yeah no
it's just smart thing to do till I give
yourself a cut-off time like I'm not
gonna drink past 2 and then I would work
it something out about a time it's about
a feeling but yes the the working it off
is also yeah cuz I can you take your eye
shot and then you go home you're you're
toast
that was me and so I was like rolling
around the car the cab I dropped I
dropped tomorrow off and then I had to
go by myself and I'm just like bopping
around this cab it was nuts cabs like
the big new cabs that like you feel
every bump like Pichet and it was so
bumpy and I was literally like I was
jello because I was so [ __ ] up and
like I was literally like Yahtzee look
you know they shake the dice like that
was me in the back of the car it's like
that's so funny
yes I'm so glad you guys made it today
we made it on time and I look beautiful
and that's really nice to see Jackie's
gonna roll up in here like bright eyes
shining down and your lipstick okay and
your loafers I'm wearing Shinyoung it
means that my hair is atrocious like my
it's not a good hair day for me I've had
like a morning where nothing was going
right I guess that's just my life it's
again Terminator came at 11:45 so I
couldn't leave until 15 minutes later
and then I was waiting for my uber that
just decided to never finish driving
towards me I thought maybe the map was
stuck try calling him he didn't pick up
and took me about like ten minutes
before he decided to cancel got in the
cab where I had to direct myself arrow
didn't work I'm outside pain with my
credit card just the credit card that
dropped in the cab oh this happened to
me in speech the other day and it was
like the epitome of my life we took a
cab yellow cab home and I wanted to add
a new card to my arrow so I took up my
wallet and I got my card out I set my
wallet down we go over a bump and my
wallet flips over and all of my credit
cards a little slide between the seats
we're on our hands and knees getting at
the card Sam you could barely see it's
disgusting and then I'm like my IDs not
here so we're literally pulling apart
seat cushions and I got it maybe like it
was just so crazy I think I got
everything I think you got everything
but it was just like that manicure
points card that's [ __ ] annoying did
you work hard for those points and
they're expensive and you know my local
nail salon just changed their rewards
system and I'm not on board with the new
plan it's like to get 200 points for a
free manicure like a manicure is
literally ten points it's 20 manicures
what do you think it's the best salon
reward it's like that a salon could do
like nine manicures get you ten free
okay or ten medicare's get one yeah
agree yeah yeah like the way that I have
it at mine it's like points like for
every dollar you spend it's like point
zero one you got 20 points and yet I can
free mani-pedi which one time when I was
in high school I mean it was like those
rewards parents had no like money and I
wouldn't have any value at 90 petty
otherwise and it really came through
but those reward programs are not
designed like to work do not I mean like
they just say be thanked for you to lose
your car yes and then it's like the
honors to someone said I'd come back on
my hey ladies
I literally had 5,000 points like can
you hook it up and she's taken a few
hundred yeah no they're not for the
faint of heart that's for sure I like
have a [ __ ] headband migraine like
where you feel secure wearing a headband
yeah so why are you allergic just been
like stopping taking my allergy
medication because like it's summer
by the way sup do you see Dan and chase
wheat they said we've been waiting five
years to tweet this but it's finally
summer 19 you and me was the first day
of summer by the way I got it and that's
their song summer of nineteen you and me
I love that finally it is Myrtle Beach
yeah yep so back to my mother man so I
can't even touch a migraine which is why
this episode is sponsored by coves if
you suffer from migraines headaches the
last thing you need to wait for it's to
see a doctor with Cove there's finally a
way to get the help you need when you
need it for a limited time you'll get
your doctor consultation a first month
of treatment for just $30 no medical
insurance required visit with cub we
took over cub Co oh yeah every time I'd
like to talk about this brand I'm always
like is it overcome its Co ve that's
cove until further notice okay so cove
is like a tailored concierge service for
people with migraines you get to talk to
real doctors it's fast they everyone
suffered like i whenever i ask people
for migraine like tips every people do
the weirdest [ __ ] that like works for
them they're like put your feet in hot
water and pees on your neck or whatever
so this is like a really tailored
program to help with your migraines and
we both get migraines and i don't think
there's anything in the world worse than
just like having to be alive with a
migraine no there's nothing there's
absolutely nothing nothing so go to with
Kove calm slash totes that's w ith CoV
e.com slash toast first month of
treatment for just $30 you get a doctor
consultation as well no medical
insurance required again that's with
Cove WI th Co ve comm slash toast love
it okay are you ready I think it's time
now that it's almost one o'clock I think
that it's wow my god my time is like so
off because I like went to bed at the
break of dawn and I just I can't wait to
do it again
are you gonna go out tonight [ __ ] no oh
I'm gonna go to the movies oh my god
tomorrow during the day doesn't it sound
like a nice day
no I like to spend my days like on the
weekend in bed yeah but like a movie is
bad
I would say with me tonight oh let's see
a Latin no but there was another one I
wanted to say what did we just say
knocking you want to see book-smart
oh yes I saw her I would see it what
about Aladdin I heard it was good
Jackson lamb is good too actually you
know I haven't heard much about it for
like a big Disney movie me neither he
said it was really good but not better
than greatest showmen perfect I mean it
I never would have thought I know but I
I didn't know like I thought me because
he loves Aladdin is his favorite Disney
movie so I thought he was gonna take it
all the way but okay I'll get tickets
okay okay you guys sound really excited
I just really like I'm disappointed in
myself
why no no sorry not myself I didn't do
anything wrong I'm disappointed like I'm
feeling let down right now I because I
just like wish we're back in the club
you know yeah no no money mates go to a
day party you're still drunk clearly a
hundred percent still drunk yeah I'm
gonna take this all the way maybe you
take a chopper out to like surf Lodge oh
my god we have to go to surf Lodge
tomorrow my god where we go well great
today I'm saying what a parties have on
Friday things happening like an office
party an office dirty jobs nobody works
yeah it's not your last night like right
not to leave because of were three like
you I it was a line around the block no
totally nobody's going to work today
it's a weekday it's a summer Friday
because it's the first Friday of summer
oh okay whatever we're doing this
weekend i it's Ben's desperta party
right right and that's really it and I'm
seeing a movie and we're going to talk
around man okay I'm so jazzed about
second round Bend oh my god I can't
handle it you guys are you know round
man do you don't have to drink you don't
have to drink I can't deal with like
driving like long distances while like
having to drink I don't know that I'll
drink I maybe have like we'll have one
glass of wine yeah but like just see
your chicken pride are you kidding out
of the alcohol I thank God for my wife
for the stars and stripes me freedom
forever why
let it ring salute the ones who died Hey
the ones that gave their eyes so we
don't have to sacrifice all the things
we love I got you Friday then I just
wanted to rap like like chicken god yeah
maybe you're going to do it
feelin Giovanni do a new song it I have
to say like CDI ride-or-die sanfur it's
one of the worst songs ever and the name
is stupid and like everything about it
is so stupid I'm feeling joking amid
that I'm feeling Giovanni actually okay
is everyone ready now that it's even
closer to one o'clock for the fast sex
stories they're not bad interests what
are the pet like what what are the fast
for it but I think it's joke what are
the fastest stories is it something that
you need to know oh I would say that the
stories are everything you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast I think the big
story of the day yesterday Lisa
Vanderpump's mother passed away but
Vanderpump rules filming is now on hold
oh Lisa Vanderpump is mourning the loss
of her mother Jean and putting
Vanderpump rules on hold Vanderpump
mother died at 84 years old this week
page six has confirmed the reality stars
making a trip to London to make funeral
arrangements in an insider revealed the
insider told us that the autopsy showed
that there was some embolism that went
to her brain she collapsed and that's
movement
we're told Banner pub 58 is very shocked
because her grandmother lived to almost
100 she was expecting the same for her
mother a really long and happy life I
mean it's already been such a tough year
for Lisa Vanderpump and this is just
gonna make her spiral even more but um
she isn't mom I know I don't even have a
dad and I'm 20 years old and she's like
60 and has a mom and a grandma she's
nanny cay that's crazy like British
people just live forever
yeah like the Queen Oh true yes let's
try this thing anyways this is sad um
for for everyone like I feel like Lisa
has experienced a lot of loss yeah
do you think it's better to experience
like a lot of loss in a short period of
time or to like over the course of like
a long period of time
experience like many different losses I
don't know because I feel as though when
it's in a short period of time like
you're ready in such a dark place just
pilot we're creating the meaning of life
just pile it on as opposed to being in
the dark place question the meaning of
life getting over that and then going
back to it yeah yeah look at like Scott
Disick who lost like both of his parents
in the short period of time you like it
really effective versus like hopefully
you know we've lost people but it's been
kind of staggered incremental we're okay
yeah so I think it's like the way that
life works it's meant to be not all at
once yeah so this must be tough for her
and I do feel for her as do i and I'm
wishing her well I will be writing her a
handwritten note I wonder if she'll
still be at Jackson Brittany's wedding
yeah oh my god she's totally not gonna
be but I am and I might be going naked
because I don't have a dress did you
like that dress that I say I did I like
I there was a bit of why tonight was my
only concern you know I mean it's like I
got this dress I should post a picture
cuz like I really don't know if it's
like it's it's black and white but it's
like white lace and no one would ever
mistake me for the bride ever
like no bride would ever wear the dress
but like is it disrespectful especially
like I feel like I'm really coming as
Jax's guest more so than Britney yes I
don't think that Britney's that kind of
girl that would mean either looking at
anyone but also I don't even like that
dress like that's what I need to do
today go shopping for a dress and like
the only thing that makes me like a
wanna tie more than shopping for a dress
is like nothing actually Wow like you
couldn't pay me to go shopping today
okay but actually we do pay you and you
have to come shopping we'll go tomorrow
yeah yeah so no I don't think but juicy
Chrissy Teigen tweeted that she was
invited to Jackson Brittany's wedding
and the try to figure out if they should
they can go oh no I didn't see like if
John and Krista go like I will die
you'll definitely be there then yeah no
I'm going I've recently made peace
because this entire like months that
since I got the invitation I guess I
don't know how to read and I thought the
wedding was on Sunday which was like a
little annoying because it's New York
pride and like I had a lot of plans and
it was really thinking about not going
to the wedding but then I found out the
weddings actually on Saturday and that I
don't know how to read so now we go into
the wedding Saturday flying back to
Sunday morning and raging it up on the
cheapy G float oh I'm so excite
for you I know that was really becoming
your costume it was like how many times
did I write in our chat like guys should
I go and like nobody ever I didn't
answer me because I didn't I didn't know
what to tell you cuz it's crossbar
worthy because it's a real Sophie's
Choice that's the thing my choices we
all have to make them including
something I don't like talking about
Sophia
it's [ __ ] we need to change it it
needs media is a great term until you
realize what her choice was was between
two choosing which one of her children
should I yeah but it's like ignorance is
bliss when it comes to Sophie's Choice
and you just think it's a Sophie's
Choice but I agree we should change the
name it's a dangerous choice who's the
Andra I don't know okay so are you
thinking of someone who like me who had
a big decision to make
hmm okay such a great question let's
think think of like a great movie
character like okay look and I just
watch it Legally Blonde red white and
blonde they got with that job at the
cosmetics company so she would leave
Washington but and they led like three
dogs out but she but she either could
have taken that small victory or passed
up on the big paycheck and gone for all
the dogs and that's what she did she had
a true else choice to make okay but like
Al's choice it's too positive it has to
be like a real like everybody movie
there's a choice to make but so who's
someone who really had to choose between
a rock and a hard place
I'm hoping the toasters can remind us of
some people you know Vivian's choice
perhaps she should choose between life
with Warner Lauren Conrad
Oh what so choice I don't know do you
think she's too good for everyone should
have gotten to Paris that's good that's
good Elsie's choice cheese choice now do
you go to Paris and further your career
or do you say home with your boyfriend I
know buddy got back together and always
be the girl who didn't go to Paris right
that's a real LC strip that line when
she when that boss from Teen Vogue's
what's up my brother no Timo he said
you'll always be the girl who didn't go
to Paris like that like struck me you
know because it's true like who was
Lauren Conrad the girl in her Paris but
do you know like now that there was no
trip to Paris oh really yeah lol I guess
you can't miss you can't lose something
you never had totally
but that ah well that's the
it's an Elsie's choice my god my ears
and make throat are just inspired okay
but where it could be don't looking the
thing it could be the rocks choice
because in the game plan he had to
choose between saving this kid and
basically Super Bowl thank you Sarah for
that very wise suggestion think of the
last movie that you watched like this
lifetime movie I watch where she had to
choose between killing her boyfriend or
just going to the airport hmm
that's really tough because I see the
benefits of both I'm gonna go with the
airport though ya know she needs to get
a boyfriend actually should have just
gotten out of there and let someone else
kill him feel the rain on your skin okay
next up Lindsay Lohan inks a record deal
following the cancellation of her
reality TV show is she feeling Giovanni
I'm feeling what do you think is the
best version of Lindsay like when she's
singing when she's acting when she's on
a reality show like what do you think
she should be doing I mean I'm not sure
but all I know is that I'm tired of room
started I'm sick of being followed I'm
sad of people Vaughn and saying what
they want about me Oh honestly like
coked-out Lindsay Lohan if singing we're
wearing the club like that is Lindsay
Lohan that I that's what she should be
doing yeah so she needs to move back to
the States
she's a record deal and it might be
happening that album the Qi release like
I feel is one of the untapped gold mines
of pop culture I'm gonna listen to it
after this yeah I mean sorry I take back
everything I said my favorite Lindsay
Lohan is the ending credits of
confession
Oh Commission's are at Freaky Friday
Freaky Friday yeah ultimate you know
right oh actually okay that like two
year period where she made back-to-back
[ __ ] bangers confessions of a teenage
daughters we had with movies yeah oh no
I meant banger movies but Confessions of
a Teenage Drama Queen Freaky Friday Mean
Girls was like a two-year period we're
like she couldn't be stopped
yeah and then we got that girl I'm gonna
watch her impressions of a teenager I'm
gonna mean this weekend because it's
really an important movie like it's
sidarthur it's the most amazing movie
carthoris like sid arthur and also when
she's trying out for
[Music]
the song has three words don't move I
don't think so like when Megan Fox and
Syd Arthur comes to his house and she's
like oh come to our house and she's like
show walking walking through it's like
he's there for her it's like such a mood
no I do know and I feel as though so
many times I'm in situations where I'm
like okay this is Meg Arthur and Megan
sit on Megan Fox's yeah like when the
three mean girls like wearing Burberry
bucket hats in the homeroom like that is
like what I want to see this again and
I'm gonna watch it good
also Herbie fully loaded and Georgia
rule Herbie fully [ __ ] loaded and
Georgian locking border rules a
different era though and it's also in
much more elevated film in the sense
that like it's really one that we need
to evaluate my life choices yeah it's a
dark fountain for shirtless and like and
they show me things about it Felicity
Huffman like the caromed the limit of it
all Garrett Hedlund Jane Fonda I don't
[ __ ] what you invite mil Ronie Dermot
Palmer stars so we're just like China
vogue her mom's boyfriend
it's so weird that's like the beginning
of man she knew Garrett had long a
[ __ ] in the canoe and he was like
feeling so ashamed to call his
girlfriend does whaling
George oral the best movie I think likes
it it literally sit here and talk about
Lindsay Lohan's like discography for
hours
Harry trap lets me not forget yeah
Lindsay Lohan has signed a record deal
with Tommy Mottola is Casablanca Records
sorry lights eyes oh my god cuz he's
[ __ ] great no matter where she goes
no matter no matter no matter so Tommy
Mottola is record company exactly wait
say that again she signed a record deal
with Tommy Mottola record company
Casablanca Records
so Tommy Mottola used to be married to
Mariah Carey now he's married to Thalia
and honestly like he makes stars out of
his wives so I think I need to marry him
I think so too
oh my god I'm so sorry like Chile I'm
not even sorry
yeah I am even if he liked
no I like I'm not sorry because that was
so amazing like I want to do it again
I'm really glad for our next story you
seem ready no I'm like so ready babe
actions I'm really happy for her show
got cancelled Mika knows part yeah and I
think he got cancelled because she
doesn't have a bar any because she
doesn't have the club no I know I know
people were going all summer like yeah
okay when I saw an episode where like
Terrence J went with golden miry and
they were like we've been to every club
in Europe this summer and like this is
the best one Wow which is a real
endorsement dude there we go
I like was scared to say it because like
I don't want it to be true it's the
perfect couple broke up because the
perfect couple broke up in my golden
Barbie just like actual golden Barbie
like she's just gold and women and the
perfect man and the Terrence just like
the nicest guy who like had the dream
job and like has continues to have
what's his job now he's just the host to
the stars yeah yeah he'd accepted that
whole are you the one thing that was
like a dark point for I'm sure it's a
big paycheck yeah and I love the show so
yeah I think he's doing well I except
for the fact that they broke up and I'm
just crushed
you know I'm crushed as well I'm not
sure they crushed for you look when I
heard it I'm like oh I wonder how this
is gonna affect Isis but the thing is
like we never even heard it they just
sort of drifted off which is nice
because it's also like they're not so
huge like celebrity wise and that we
need constant updates on the
relationship so that's like a nice level
of Fame debate like you can break up
with your boyfriend like a piece okay
cardi B has been indicted in connection
with a wild strip club brawl
I heard rapper cardi B has been indicted
by a Queen's grand jury in connection
with a wild bra at a queen strip club
where she allegedly roughed up two
bartenders a spokeswoman for the Queens
District Attorney's Office confirmed to
the post on Friday morning that the
boudic yellow rapper whose name is Belle
callous almond czar has been indicted in
connection with the case but would not
confirm the charges ahead of the stars
arraignment next week
TMZ reported early Friday that the 14
charges include two counts of felony
attempted assault with intent to cause
serious physical injury as well as
misdemeanor reckless endangerment
assault criminal solicitation conspiracy
and Harris
okay I just want to say I don't condone
violence or crime but I kind of like
love that cardi B like walks the walk
and talks the talk like she raps about
[ __ ] up [ __ ] and now she's getting
indicted for it like that's what
criminal justice system works like right
she's really like that [ __ ] I feel that
you know what she's true dur like I feel
like some rappers like to you know
rapping about like getting [ __ ] I'm
like they stay home and like live in
their mom's basement so you know like
she raps about what she knows and what
she does and like well like again I do
not condone violence
I just appreciate the authenticity in
her bread I feel like Nicki Minaj hasn't
done half the things she raps about I
get I'm not putting women against
another right um I just said I can this
doesn't sound like a big deal to me
because as far as like being
disappointed in cardi B for her actions
like nothing will ever be worse than
like drugging and stealing from men so
she didn't
oh yeah yeah so like a strip club brah
okay yeah this is okay
yeah I can't explain it like the word
indicted is scare honey it's like what
did she commit financial crimes no I
know also mail fraud ooh that cardi B is
B cardi Bacardi yeah the beverage and
her sisters names Hennessy but that's
not even there really no I know but like
it's not quite in fact yeah you know me
I'm just always want to share an
interesting factoid that I find to be
well oh yeah interesting imagine being
on the jury like in this case it must be
so hard to find a jury for that because
like everyone's biased like someone's
team Nikki you know yeah most her team
cardi yeah I think I denied it cuz she's
America's Sweetheart she'd be like
that's the thing she is yeah I [ __ ]
love her I agree and every time she goes
live on Instagram I feel like so seen
and heard I hope this doesn't mean like
jail time or anything would she do a
video like how she Shops at Target make
people come up they're like what are you
doing here she's like I'm shopping what
are you doing here what are you Jimmy
here like a random ordinary places like
she needs toilet paper like just regular
stuff she's like what do you think I'm
stealing I'm shopping that's funny
comedy next up ariana grande has a new
tattoo inspired by this iconic Jim
Carrey movie ariana grande continues to
keep fans on their toes with every
tattoo she got
on Thursday the 25 year old thank you
next pop star revealed her latest
addition a famous quote inspired by her
favorite Jim Carrey movie unfortunately
not a sin to rise okay what would you
say your favorite Jim Carrey movie you
sent her a pet detective
honestly though Evan Almighty is the
second close oh if the second close a
close second
you think yeah there's so many like
things that we say like in everyday life
that actually started from Evan Almighty
like what I'm not sure but I just have a
feeling that that's it okay taking tea
Oh alrighty then oh no baby that's
pintura oh it's from her tattoos from
The Truman Show oh you know that movie
it's like super sad and I don't know I
just like don't want to see Jim Carrey
like making me cry yeah yeah this whole
tattoo thing is that taking to Instagram
stories the brunette beauty reposted her
BFF and cousin Courtney chip alone ease
new tattoo which happens to be the same
thing she got quote I got the same [ __ ]
but upside down she captioned her post
Truman Show Ariana and Courtney's new
ink is an iconic line from the
critically acclaimed drama D it reads
quote in case I don't see a good
afternoon good evening and good night
while chip alone showed off her new
design which she got down on her left
shoulder it's unclear where Ariana got
hers what does kind of morbid thing too
right yeah it's like I'll never see you
again
yeah you'll never see me again she
should have gotten that by Tamra touch
yeah that's a good one anyways I'm just
like I'm just worried for her I know and
look what she hit it upside down like
enough well she just is upside down I
know I like that pictures I'm looking
following her Instagram like I have to
literally turn my phone around like just
[ __ ] post like everyone else I'm just
like we're not sure she just announced
like a bunch of new tour dates and if I
know that's the she's going back to that
York I know I saw it on Twitter and I'm
like girl go to sleep god it's like I
don't think honestly that she can't go
to sleep like yeah so she just keeps
herself busy but like oh there's things
to go on vacation you know take all your
friends you have such great friends like
get a house in like no you have multiple
horse in Caicos I just have like a
month-long vacation I want to do music
that could be a fun thing I wanted to
update everyone I
a shower yesterday right after the test
okay how did it feel it's all good I'm
happy for you it felt really good
know that I am um I had one more thing I
wanted to add re go to sleep
vacations girls no job calm oh you know
that isn't what I wanted to add but I
could always do a good plug for my tour
let me just burp um he had the tours can
we let Richmond Virginia San Diego Las
Vegas all hit in this summer Lexington
Kentucky next week there's only like a
few seats left there um and we're gonna
be in LA this fall and work she gonna do
I think toast to LA we yeah we talked
about that about doing like some podcast
episodes out in LA that works for me
making the LA show a bit of a bit of a
scene you know I heard I heard about
this coming but I think I I can neither
confirm nor deny this or worse uh I
think we spoken about this before but if
you were to get a tattoo what would you
get I'd put on the bottom of my foot so
no could see it cuz I'm not like into
the whole thing except look for myself
and it would say Baca yeah I think I
would get something in Hebrew I don't
know what it is but I've seen you vibe
I like this yeah like that jacket oh
that's what I would get rockstein vibes
in Hebrew because I think the senior
vibes now are are eternal yeah it's like
you never know when something's just
like trendy or like things just come in
and out of your life but senior vibes
are forever 18 I'm sorry for ever
Roxy died friends come and go Jeanie
backs our fifth and final story little
weather news because like I said it's
the first day of summer and in case you
were wondering midsummer to early fall
temperatures are expected to be mild in
central us however hot as hell near the
coast is that torture that's weather
calms where it's hot as hell
it is no weather commas like always you
know like revolutionising the weather
industry you know there's really no
competition and they're always getting
it wrong because that's what
meteorologists do is just they say
something hope it's right turns out to
be wrong oh it's like they're the host
of the morning toast temperatures across
parts of the Midwest planes in Rockies
may be slightly cooler than average into
early fall but above average
temperatures are expected over the next
few months closer towards the east and
west coast so here in New York we will
be having a warmer
than usual and I feel ready for that
because I feel as though last time I was
cold like we were just talking about
when we were in a sea and it was so
[ __ ] windy and was the middle of July
I know like there's very few times when
I want it to be warm for the most part
I'll take a cold summer like that
weekend in Atlantic City like we were
out at the pool and it's [ __ ]
freezing like oh hey bad I understand
that it's like a rare exception we're
like I want a breeze B usually I'm good
no but like even when we are talking
that women went to cerclage like it was
so [ __ ] breezy and I just want summer
vibe a breeze never bothered me like no
like a wind where your hair doesn't like
stay in its part that's [ __ ] annoying
so [ __ ] annoying man hey focus and
I'm thinking like all the weekends I
summer when I did something like in New
York like went to the Hamptons once or
just AC once they were cold and rainy
and windy yeah so like I'd rather have
like a hot weekend okay am I alone in
like I might be alone in this but like
when the weather like sabotages summer
plans like that involve like bathing
suits like I am like so happy like when
I was in high school and like we all
like planned a weekend like in the
Hamptons there's something and then it
rained and like all my skinny friends I
couldn't like run around in their
bathing suits like that's too bad for
you of [ __ ] course and I love when
like the weather ruins like other
people's plans like yeah especially if I
was like I there's nothing I love more
than when it's raining and staying home
and watching it rain and just being so
glad I don't have to deal with an
umbrella right like I wish it rained in
Paris tonight so that cruise agent
outside was ruined oh she got married
she got married oh my god betches bride
wearing to the deck it ends on Saturday
okay betches brides was doing this like
Sauvage ray coverage so much so that
they went private and ice of eyes like
savage like mean yeah but they started
being so nice like she's gotten the Hat
I think everyone thought at first it was
like a cute like scavenger hunt but like
when it goes on three days and we found
out you they tried to pitch it for a TV
show
yeah it's gonna be a no from Asus so yes
I kind of wish her crop top oh she had a
crop top wedding dress wait I haven't
kept up in a while ever since I saw the
day oh and then it's like over they got
married they got sitting on two chairs
and I'll show you can't get married in
France
you've someone else' be living there for
40 consecutive days that's why I like
Sophie and Joe so it's like a fake
wedding I think
and she took goop out of her Instagram
handle and I actually did DM Gweneth
today and I said what's going on but she
did answer again oh my god that is so
crazy I'm sorry and I I'm officially
taking the crown off of Maria Menounos
his head firm biggest loser and I'm
getting into this girl sorry like this
is at first like I was like oh my god
and like everyone else and now like
everyone else I'm like this is annoying
and now the vibe that I got from the
toaster I've been following along um
they're like really let down like the
people who have been following this so
like that's it was like it was like a
photographer using an iPhone like it was
just not premium um I think they have
all this premium content and they're
gonna like try and make more stuff that
we could consume but it just really was
bothering me like when you found say she
didn't know and she found out she was
getting engaged and then her fiance like
center on the scavenger hunt and like
first she has to do a flywheel class
like I just would have been like so
upset and then she gets her glam squad
done to sit in the car
she was supposed take a blade fine but
so she sits in the car for like hours to
Montauk where she just has a night in
with her friends like Gurney's on a
Tuesday night you know I don't know but
I think so why'd she get all her hair
and makeup done can I tell you Olivia
pointed out literally the funniest thing
about this everything I know about this
I've gotten information from Olivia but
so like the the the bride and her
friends are on the toasters group and
they're reading all the feedback oh did
you say yet and they're reading all the
feedback and then like influencing her
content cuz like her boyfriends finding
her around the world that giving her
gifts and she's like so like bratty
about it is he wanted her to go to
Hewlett and I understand I understood
her because they were in Montauk they
just sat in the car for so long and then
he wants her to go to Hewlett which it's
actually really far away considering
they're both on Long Island she's like
I'm not gonna heal it I don't want to go
to heal it you know they think you the
girl in the back where I was like what
do you mean we're going to the Seawind
club they have the best and got cut up
and I want to talk to that girl and she
said no to that oh she's so ungrateful
right but so everyone was saying like
she seems so ungrateful but I understood
it was becoming hard she doesn't know
for sure for sure but in so funny cuz
all all the comments were now like
sweating towards her being like a brat
and being ungrateful for like all these
beautiful things that she has so when
she saw that she goes on her phone sick
stop and say like how grateful I am like
to Gabe and like you know only friends
and it's like I just want to keep
influencing and I just oh my god way and
women's work gently oh my god
Women's Wear Daily did a story on it and
they promoted it on their Instagram so
they put a picture whatever and they
called her an aspiring influencer that
is so mean well that's horrifying I mean
she's she's an influencer now how many
followers is she at I just I have so
many thoughts on this whole thing like I
could just I could talk about it and
nasi I'm like the deck and the
speculation and like the fact that okay
she said she didn't have anything to do
with the deck like her team get it but
like when she started this she had a
hundred or thirty I was a Minster
grandfather what team does she want team
do you need or that her husband did it
but like he works at JPMorgan and like
how would he know how to make and talk
about influencing yeah no she fully made
the deck I can't she used her Boop
computer computer I can't deny chant and
and I went and it's so it's over yes
they got married but it's like not real
I think they'll probably stuff to go to
City Hall of course they will but like
they got married via a rabbi and the
whole thing was like they were gonna get
engaged in married in like one or two
days because they didn't want a long
engagement like to be super extra have
their friends spend all this money and
it's like nothing has been more extra
than everything you just did right and
it's like now you're the most extra girl
in the world
gratulations oh my gosh I just can't
what this stupidity and like her like I
mean I haven't seen any of the content
and everything I'm saying is like
secondhand paraphrasing but like
apparently in Miami Beach like drops to
the floor like Tinsley when Scott
surprised sir like junk cats on the
floor like she's like on the floor in
the middle of a crowded Lobby would like
all of her friends filming her she's
just like overwhelmed you know she's
like all the press I'm like the press I
would just like you have so much
adrenaline the moment you find out
you're getting engaged and for that to
go on for days and you don't see your
fiance like that's just a woman in love
like I would be like literally
physically in pain like just with the
excitement and they would they would
like it would give me a stomachache like
Oh like imagine finding out like we're
getting engaged in like you have that
feeling of like when women for three
days how do you sleep like yeah we just
it would drive me insane that I would
get to Paris and I would say no Jackie
I'm going on my own
Jackie how this goes I mean the girl who
did this goes without saying these two
people have to stay together forever
because I don't know what will happen to
them if they don't like the world
implode yeah like I need them to have a
lifetime of happiness they'd have to be
happy together you know what like if
this is what she wanted and this is and
he did all of this and they're meant to
be together and I and I love love still
stuff I wish them a lifetime of
happiness because the alternative is
just too sad to think about yeah the
thinking about her adrenaline and having
to go to a so psycho class like with you
so you're sitting on a bike like riding
for an hour like wondering when you're
getting a gauge awful unless she didn't
know hopefully she knew otherwise I
would jump man I would jump out of my
skin with like anxiety you know mm-hmm
right yeah and then she went to the spa
from what I'm getting engaged in him
laying out a massage table like though
the whole thing I'm not gonna lie like
and I she's in the car for hours to
Gurney's in traffic in the rain jacket
and then actually and I've always said
this I think that like judging and being
mean about someone's wedding it's like
the meanest the most evil thing you
could do like my myrrh and Stassi was a
evo about Sheila's wedding like I firmly
stand on Sheena side still but this girl
like put herself so out there like open
to negativity that like she has to know
that this is what's the reality and like
I think this is the lousiest thing I
just wanted to put it out there I agree
and also in terms of I'm just like
putting myself in her shoes in the
adrenaline and the anxiety would make me
go insane also then all the stories like
I could barely story enough last night
at you know it stresses me out like yeah
and then they're tagging all these
brands like and so if she did know and
now she has all this work to do plus her
like for her mental state I hope that
she didn't know because this is would
just be too much for one person like
yeah and it's like okay I have to say
something like getting married is great
but it's not that big of a deal like
they're made seem like she's going to
space like it's a biggest deal in the
world like every it's Mary just like do
it and figure it out you know like it
just have to be huge to like do it in
the city like just I just want to know
the GUP of it all like that's where I'm
at and I'm infiltrating witness I'm
gonna actually like give her a phone
call like I'm gonna find out um and I
just she's getting a lot of followers
though so it's working so but they'll
all unfollow once you things like forty
thousand people will remember turn
follow they will be engaged no I think
I think she should it worked yes you got
what you wanted but she'll never like
this is the thing when you do like viral
stunts like that you can gain a lot but
you can also lose a lot so she can a lot
of followers but she lost ever like
she'll never be like a respected
influencer in the space and she does her
job I think she lost her job yeah she
lost her job she took goop out of her
thing and then maybe just because goop
didn't want okay bitching I don't think
she lost her job okay but first of all
like she hasn't at work deserve she
hasn't been at work in a week okay
people take PTO you know Women's Wear
Daily said this according to a source
close to goop company leadership was
surprised by few kisses extensive
branding effort and had no involvement
in the social media proposal or
knowledge of it ahead of time
Fuchs is also removed her job title from
her Instagram bio replacing it with the
hashtag where is Gabe okay I don't think
she lost her job if she lost her job
I'll be really disappointed in sad for
her because also everyone in the office
that's when she watched the first video
was in on it filming her so like there
was a some level of people knowing and
people had to know cuz her co-workers
got her where she needed to be I think
she's like good at her job and I think
just goof doesn't want the attention and
they don't want to be mentioned in every
story about it so she took it out of her
bio for now but I really hope she
doesn't lose her job yet if she didn't
do anything really really thirsty she
actually could have a good lawsuit on
her hands for wrongful termination
yeah like thirst is not grounds for
dismissal no can be oh my god I'm just
like literally gonna lay in bed for the
rest today like on the chopping yeah I
have to catch up on Maroney which was
last night eat me too I started this
morning I'm almost done oh wow good you
had a big busy morning
well I thought you might have watched it
since you did go to bed at 8:00 a.m. no
I mean 8:00 p.m. I won and I did not
watch it but I watched a and
the honey browser I [ __ ] love that
you have it oh yeah the honey browser
I've been doing like a really
embarrassing amount of online Jen honey
is the only thing that makes me feel
better about it so something we can all
agree on saving money honey is a free
browser extension that scans the web for
coupon codes and discounts while you
shop so basically like you just shop
like regular you have the little thing
installed in your browser and then by
the time you checkout it pops up and
it's like hey let us save you 1 million
dollars and you click it and it does it
Auto pies oh my god I actually deserve
I'm sorry it applies automatically honey
automatically applies the biggest
savings to your cart checkout like magic
it works on over 20,000 sites like
Amazon Nordstrom j.crew Nike Best Buy
Target Macy's and more it takes zero
effort to install two clicks and you'll
start saving every time you shop you
shop online there's no reason not to use
honey it's free to use easy to install
on your computer in just two clicks
don't take it from us take it from our
listeners get honey for free at join
honey calm / toast again that's join
honey J oin h o n ey comm slash toast
online savings simplified via honey it's
free I mean I'm yeah I don't think we do
any ads for something free it's a
wonderful wonderful thing it really like
you're already gonna shop and honey
we'll just make sure you're saving money
everywhere that you can it actually like
the greatest thing that ever happened to
me and it's one of the few brands that
sponsor the show that I used before yeah
yeah so it's like you know a Campari
moment I used to be Bates but it's like
that me too and if the computer that I
used for tour is the one that has the
base on it was pop it up so [ __ ]
Anthony is a silent friend yeah talk
about today uh no I just hope everyone
has a great weekend I hope you guys feel
better but I'm so happy for you and your
big night out thank you honestly like
you know the dust is settled and you
know the Sun has risen and and I'm
looking back on my time like laughing
was literally like The Hangover like
that's how I feel like the movie it was
like just so much happened you notice
and we were true remember the day we
traversed yeah we were in every every
part of this city we were there there's
something hilarious that you'll
appreciate Elise I was talking to
someone who had the world's worst breath
and I just wasn't having it so Margaret
Lestrade splinter group no I don't wanna
say but no no no go and I'm Margaret
Listerine spray so I was like standing
with a bunch of people and I was like
giving H everyone but like mainly for my
targeted you know person and I was like
you want you know like everyone else
took it Margot's Listerine spray is
insane
it was like it was so crazy I got two
puffs
it works it works a little too well it's
like Marlon yeah cambers we're out that
says head that's as hard as it gets
campus is out like a light I did
Listerine last night it was crazy
you guys don't knock it till you've
tried it no it's true okay
that's all she wrote Oh write it I just
like to get out of this chair it's now
1:30 if your office to summer fridays
you only have an hour and a half less of
the day which you know been summer
fridays like ended earlier i think oh
when i used to work for the proper dog
be a cog in the corporate machine summer
fridays ended at 3:00 o'clock so it's
like like that's not even early like
about a job i would leave at 3:00 every
day like that's [ __ ] late the days
over 30 o'clock so anyways enjoy your
first friday of summer even though it's
raining here in new york but we are
about to have an above our just
temperature of summer so peace Wow
thanks for tuning in late
you